quatre jours après les explosions à
beyrouth dont ils tiennent la classe
politique responsable
les protestataires se sont rassemblés
d'abord à la place des martyrs
ils ont pris d'assaut le qg de
l'association des banques et le
ministère des affaires étrangères qu'ils
ont proclamé quartier général de la
révolution les altercations entre la
folle et les policiers ont d'ailleurs
fait une première victime parmi les
policiers
plus d'une centaine d'autres personnes
ont aussi été blessées au cours des
affrontements
le premier ministre hassan diab a évoqué
des élections anticipées pour sortir de
cette crise
une proposition visiblement
insuffisantes pour en parler je joins au
bout du fil
ali murad il est professeur de droit à
beyrouth -participer justement
manifestation d'aujourd'hui bonjour
monsieur mourad
bonjour bonjour alors avant de parler de
cette proposition du premier ministre de
quoi avez vous été témoin des routes
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui des routes étaient au
maintien
nous avons bâti les barricades on est
dans une dans une perspective
révolutionnaire le changement la crise a
du bon c'est une crise de gouvernance et
un crise d'un système politique ce n'est
pas une crise d'un gouvernement ou juste
appelé pour des élections anticipées
vous avez dit dans votre reportage qu'on
a collé que les gens en prise de
ministères des affaires étrangères c'est
vrai mais aussi les ministères de
l'énergie et des deux ministères de
l'économie et de la deux
et de l'en déloger des oueds et le
bûcher des vanités des exactement là cet
espace est le suivant monsieur ce qui se
passe c'est que après l'explosion de 4 à
2 4 août dernier cela signifie qu on est
en rupture totale avec le système
politique la responsabilité de ce qui
s'est passé on est dans une dans une
approche de ce qui s'est passé à
tchernobyl
c'est la faillite d'un tout un système
pour l'éthique c'est la responsabilité
de ce système politique corrompu qui a
conduit on a va attendre un peu les
résultats des investigations criminelles
mais c'est pas la priorité la priorité
c'est le départ de tous ceux de tous les
personnes qui dirigent ce pays depuis
une trentaine d'années qui ont conduit
le pays à la faillite nos divisions
confessionnelles et tout ça et donc cela
on ne peut pas se faire à travers des
des changements on va dire de face non
on a besoin d'un changement radical et
ce changement radical passe à travers la
rue et à travers on pour imposer pour
percer ce pouvoir dont la rue bon alors
on comprend bien dans vos propos
monsieur mourad que les élections
anticipées proposé par le premier
ministre à ses diables ne sont pas
suffisantes à vos yeux qu'est ce que la
solution donc politique pour sortir de
cette crise
pendant les élections anticipées c'est
l'aboutissement d'une période de deuil
période transitionnelle
on a besoin d'un gouvernement
transitionnel peut-être on a beau
n'aurait besoin d'un d'un comité de
salut national qui va conduire plus tard
à la formation d'un gouvernement
d'indépendants et au bout de 7 de cette
chaîne
on va passer par les élections
anticipées dans notre pays les élections
est un moyen pour que cette classe
politique serait capable de renouveler
de se renouveler à nouveau non non on a
besoin d'un changement radical surtout
aussi que la loi électorale
elle est élue ce type de problème car le
german denis appliquer ce n'est dans ses
lois électorales c'est un c'est un moyen
qui permet à cette classe politique de
ceux de ce2 se renouveler
trois mots nabeul exactement le
découpage électoral et aussi comment
établir un système mais conventionnelles
dont il ya beaucoup de détails
on a pas de confiance dans ce
gouvernement à conduire à cette loi
électorale on a aussi besoin que le
parlement il arrête d'exercer ses
fonctions nous on est dans une approche
révolutionnaire surtout qu'après
qu'après l'explosion de 4 août
on a pas on a plus de privilèges de de
trouver un compromis avec ce pouvoir
soit le départ soit la confrontation
alors ça va plus ça va plus loin
monsieur mourad que simplement remplacer
les figures politiques qui sont au
pouvoir présentement au liban bien sûr
bien sûr nous on n'a pas besoin de
changer maintenant quelques figures on
n'a plus besoin de changer le thème
l'approchent la gouvernance de ce pays
la gouvernance économique la gouvernance
politique même la gouvernance
sécuritaire là aujourd'hui
à mon avis les services de sécurité ils
ont tout intérêt à ne plus obéir aux
ordres de pouvoir politique et donc au
minimum note de neutraliser leurs
positions ne plus attaquer attaquer les
gens là aujourd'hui les gens ils ont
haussé le ton en décidant de rentrer
dans l'est dans les halls et dans les
laits sujet de certains ministères cela
cela est un signe de rupture totale avec
le pouvoir ce qui s'est passé commencé à
17 octobre on est on est on a dépassé le
seuil de confrontation c'est la
radicalisation maximale de la
confrontation avec le pouvoir politique
les avons rencontrées vers que ce
pouvoir politique est un pouvoir
d'occupation qui occupent l'état et ses
institutions et qui kidnappe la
population au liban où elle est
justement l'occupation de ces ministères
c'est un geste assez fort un geste
symbolique mais très très fort en
terminant à monsieur mourad ça ne semble
pas être dans les intentions des membres
du gouvernement de céder leur place du
moins à court terme qu'est ce que vous
voyez c'est à prévoir donc dans les
prochains jours le premier ministre pour
le dire très franchement c'est une
marionnette entre les mains d'éléments
des partis politiques qui gouvernent
surtout le bloc du président de la
république et ses alliés donc là le
premier ministre n'a pas son destin
entre ses mains
c'est une marionnette et les autres les
autres ministres n'ont aucune aucune
aucune présence au mas légitimité
populaire donc à mon avis si ces
ministères peut-être système des
ministres commencent à démissionner cela
nous rapproche du changement
gouvernemental mais nous on va pas
attendre peut-être l'une des solutions
c'est de faire une rupture un point
d'arrêt de du processus constitutionnel
assad ce pouvoir parte et upa une fois
que ceux de ce pouvoir
il est cette classe politique aline
cassé au fond dans ce cas là on peut
retourner aux posters et au processus
des procédures constitue un monsieur
mourad c'est tout le temps qu'on avait
mais on comprend bien dans vos propos
que qu'après des mois de protestation
ces explosions sont la goutte d'eau qui
a fait déborder le vase est vraiment un
ras-le-bol
merci merci beaucoup encore une fois
d'avoir été avec nous pour témoigner là
vous êtes professeur de droit à beyrouth
est manifestement pris un gros merci